sponsored by step finance your go
to d5 portfolio manager on solana
luna if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys anna welcome back to another episode
of the lay higher plan show today we are talking
all things crypto we're talking about the markets
because who really knows where we're at right now
maybe my guest will so as usual this is powered
by the vc firm icon plus capital and it is also
sponsored by block fight if you're interested
there is a link in the description and in the
comments section you can get around 250 when you
sign up and they offer amazing interest rates
so let's kick things off joining me
today is rao powell he's the founder
and ceo of global macro investor and of real
vision let's bring rao on how you doing ral
i'm great how are you i'm good thank you i'm
good it's been a while since we last chatted so
balance so i lost you then you froze
can you hear me okay yeah i can now okay perfect
how are things going on down in the cayman islands
what do you do all day there me i'm just 14 hours
of meetings all day on zoom so i am crazy busy
apart from the weekends because every weekend is
a caribbean holiday wow it sounds pretty amazing
i've never been i'd have to check it out one day
um white sand beaches turquoise clear warm water
it sounds like you're living the life but ralph
can we please get a portfol a portfolio update
before we go into this i know you're constantly
switching up changing your holdings you know
you're bullish on different metaverse coins nfts
one moment you're all in on bitcoin now i know
not now can we get a portfolio update i actually
don't change my portfolio often at all so the only
answer okay i did is i started in 2020 all in on
bitcoin then i started shifting towards ethereum
then i bought a basket which included a bunch of
metaverse plays some social tokens some um layer
ones other stuff and i basically kept that so i
don't think i've traded anything apart from buying
some nfts um and then yeah i the only other major
switch was i got i sold most of my bitcoin for
ethereum um about six nine months ago yeah okay
so probably i'm probably still 85 percent each and
then 15 other stuff see even i think that is huge
all that youth but we'll get into it before we do
um i want to know your opinion on earth happened
at the end of last year we were all sort of
expecting this super cycle um and we didn't quite
get it what happened i think two things happened
first firstly price got ahead of network activity
so what happened was people weren't there weren't
there wasn't a lot of new transactions
in the network either value transacted
wasn't going up and the number of new
wallets or active wallets wasn't going up
so price went up and the network didn't and
it didn't stick and the issue was inflation
so why does inflation matter well because the
cryptos still a retail network right it's really
driven by retail and if you've raised prices on
people and wages don't go up as much they've got
less discretionary income that discretionary
income was the dollar cost averaging that went
into crypto and so people stopped because they
had to pay their grocery bills or their rent
so that's why it just stopped so it shows how
macroeconomics influences crypto markets in ways
that people don't quite yet understand but that
was the big that was the big thing that happened
end of last year and has continued to
weigh on the market this year because
network growth hasn't really improved so
we've seen rotations within the market
so we saw people switching from each to
layer ones and we saw nfts hold their value
you know stuff as people are reallocating what
they've got in the market generally reallocating
eth um you know a lot of bitcoin people you know
tend to stick with bitcoin um but a lot of the
eth people reallocated different parts of eth like
you know nfts particularly got a lot of attention
you make an interesting point about inflation
because a lot of people sort of say oh you know
inflation's up and so the market's going to
go because people are going to be moving to
bitcoin um bitcoin's down today inflation
apparently is at new record highs today
eight and a half percent um in the us so where
do you think we're at with the market right now
it's a bit of a confusing situation um
we can talk about cycles in a minute but
where specifically do you think we're at with
the market the balance of probabilities is that
we made the low last year we retested the
low this year and i think the low is in
but who the hell really knows right so you know i
got the back end of last year wrong like everybody
else i thought you know we were going to get this
run and and we didn't see it i think we've thrown
a war eight and a half percent inflation the
fed raising interest rates all at crypto um
we've thrown chinese ban we've thrown so much at
it and it didn't make a new low kind of usually
that's a signal the market kind of has found its
its bottom and so now we're looking for okay what
are the upside catalysts the upside catalyst
would be if economic growth starts slowing
um we're likely to see then long duration assets
things that um tend to outperform in low growth
environments and crypto tends to very well in in
that kind of environment much like kathy woods
arc does those kind of you know longer term assets
so that's what we're looking for um as the spark
i think is a is a change in structure so people
fear inflation less and stop fearing growth more
yeah and i think it's interesting to see how
you mention china there and the market seems to
be quite desensitized at this point to all the
fud that comes out of china um you know which
is incredibly bullish for the the maturity of the
market but a lot of a lot i've been watching a lot
of content online and people like willy woo for
example sort of say that this idea of these four
year cycles driven by bitcoins halving is over
i personally don't know where i stand on that so
where do you sound on that do you think these four
year cycles are over given how much institutional
money we now have flowing into it uh yeah i think
it's over because the market is much larger than
it was and bitcoin is not as dominant so at the
margin the four year cycle will have an impact
but not as large an impact you know for
example the 2.0 thing is going to create
a potential dynamic that's different so
um i think i think the cycles have changed
and i think you know over time these very volatile
trends get less volatile and we saw that with
amazon in its early days it was like up and down
95 percent then 65 percent and then just gets less
and less and less because more people are in the
network so it's the same with crypto now you know
there's there's 600 million people 300 million
people using it now so what's happening is the
volatility dampened so you know the i think the
new down 85 percent is the new down 50 is the down
50 where we are now so it's kind of like we've
had a bear market we've been in a bear market
for a year you know could it go down 65 possibly
but you know it's unlikely to go down 85 percent
people have a very recency bias and they
only unders they only know what they know
and people who've been in the bitcoin market have
only been around you know a network adoption model
for a decade so they've only seen a few cycles
but if you go to facebook amazon google they've
all had these for decades and you can see how they
work and they tend to lower volatility over time
so you don't think we'd necessarily have to wait
an entire four years with that cold cold winter
until we see a new all-time high no no i don't
it's possible but i don't think it's the most
likely outcome now i think you know we just need
the macro environment to shift a bit um and we've
got different players in the market and it's a
much deeper market there now than it used to be
by the way i think there's a little bit of a
delay between your nights probably on my end yeah
it's on my end so don't worry about it i'll just
wait a little bit until you'll finish explaining
um i was actually just at the bitcoin
conference which was amazing by the
way so many interesting speakers um and there was
some very fascinating announcement one particular
um announcement actually caught my eye it was
the news that strike is partnering with ncr and
shopify so what do you think this means for the
crypto market i've seen a lot of people say that
uh sorry i lost you again there your stream is a
bit patchy um i think overall this is all great
um using bitcoin as a payment rail now whether
it's was you know i don't think it massively
helps the bitcoin network because the use of slots
on the blockchain is relatively limited and how
um lightning works but it allows it to use um to
create faster payment rails for certain things
because let's face it most people the purpose of
bitcoin is not to buy your goods or certainly not
now maybe in 20 or 30 years time the purpose of
bitcoin right now is to hold it um and you know
as a store of value and the last thing you want to
do is is buy something um you know some everyday
grocery on it because it doesn't make sense
because the expected future return is so high
so but using blockchain rails and and bitcoin
rails to power a payment system i think is great
and it's a fantastic development and the
work that uh jack is doing and all of this
is fantastic news but i don't think it's it's
it only at the margin drives active addresses
or value exchange which are the two things
that drive the value of of bitcoin itself
and i know you're bullish on ethereum
and really just the um you know web 3
the metaverse the crypto industry sort of
as a whole and if you don't think people are
gonna want to spend their bitcoin um simply
because you know it's bitcoin it's gold 2.0
how do you see the future of payments then what
are people going to be transacting and do you
think we really will come off the dollar and
be transacting on some form of cryptocurrency
well the entire web 3 world currently transacts
on um ethereum everything's priced in ethereum
everything in the metaverse is priced in ethereum
does that mean that that stays that way who the
hell knows you know i'm no ethereum maximalist i
don't know but right now that's where it is you
know every nft is basically pricing ethereum some
are now being priced in solana so we don't really
know i don't think the dollar goes away for a long
long time um you know that the dollar is so deeply
entrenched it is the largest network of anything
on earth pretty much and that's hard to get rid
of but at the margin does crypto take over more of
the payment system in this digital world for sure
and different things i think you know i think one
of the best examples of the use of bitcoin for
example has been what uh terra has done using
it as collateral i always said it's fantastic
collateral it's actually not great for payments
um yes um you know the lightning network can solve
different things of that but really is collateral
it's fantastic and that's what terra have done
it's a great idea and that we will see more of
that this is only the start of i think people
using bitcoin as the collateral layer also
we'll see as opposed to central banks using
it we'll definitely see sovereign wealth funds
um owning bitcoin because it's a long duration
savings asset so it works perfectly for them so
those i think are the bigger developments that
will develop for the bitcoin ecosystem over time
um in terms of payments we don't really know yet
stable coins i think are still in their infancy so
that's the dollar winning out still because stable
coins are dollars but for a pure web three worlds
we've seen that is currently uh the king of that
so the internet is pretty rough i just caught the
last bit of what you were saying um in terms of
being you know the the main driver of that
web 3 world um but i'm still interested in
i'm still interested in you know the growth of the
lightning network um and whether you think there's
any possibility that just because it is growing
so much and we are seeing what's happening with
strike we could start to see um ethereum perhaps
be made redundant in some in some way do you think
that's just an absolute impossibility it's what i
hear from bitcoin maxis quite a lot they're just
different things i i just don't know i mean we
don't care if i'm sending you a pound or a dollar
we don't care what network it goes on whether it
goes on some ethereum layer 2 or a bitcoin layer 2
we don't really care so i think we'll be sending
money whatever money over all sorts of different
networks and the more interoperable this world
gets the more we don't care you just want your
money sent to you immediately um so we're
not you know stripes not really about sending
bitcoin around it's about sending dollars
using blockchain rails so it's much quicker
dollars or euros or pounds same as bottle pay
do as well um that's now owned by um nydig
so i think that's good and i don't think there's
it's not competition amongst blockchains i think
different people can offer different
solutions it's essentially creating a
you know like a stable coin element of being
able to move money around fast and that's great
i definitely agree with you um i generally
take a maxi position other than um being a
freedom maxi but that's another conversation
um so what would you say it is then because
this sounds so obvious but what would
you say if people don't un um and solana
what are they missing what are they missing when
it comes to ethan solana they're they're confusing
what bitcoin is and trying to impose that
onto something else it's like saying well the
dog doesn't look like a cat and it doesn't purr
therefore it's a useless cat yeah well it's a dog
it's as simple as that ethereum is just not
the store of valley now ethereum maxis will
say well you know it's going to be this ultra hard
currency i don't really care big point is a better
solution for that because of its um further
decentralization and security of the network
so it does a perfect job ethereum is not trying to
be that ethereum is trying to be the open internet
you know the the web three the the the new layer
so again i think they interact together and i
think bitcoin is this collateral base layer right
now it's not being used as collateral and ethic
is being uh is being used as collateral but ether
has been used as a lot of collateral for all of d5
um and eth staking does that um but that's what
and solana is just a faster cheaper version of
ethereum and it's less uh it's less decentralized
so that's a trade-off and that's okay too
and i don't go oh my god solana why should that
exist it's ridiculous it exists because people
want cheaper and faster and and they they don't
care about the maximum decentralization bitcoin
people care about the maximum decentralization
monero people care about about the um privacy
they're all different use cases they're all just
different technologies for different things and
and that's okay i just don't see why there's an
argument over well why can't b well ethereum's
not bitcoin no it was never supposed to be
yeah that's the thing i always say you know
you said people dislike the fact that um by
ethereum max is just being promoted as this hard
money decentralized you know truly decentralized
hard money store of value um so i guess maybe
perhaps that's sort of where the the tribalism
comes in i'm not sure um but i do have a couple
of things anybody who's extreme in any point of
view is always going to rile somebody else up
you won't roll somebody else up if you just
say look you know we can all coexist and
they're all fine and everybody's got a good
use case and and the market will decide in
the end i mean that's it that's all there
is to it it's true the market does decide
because ultimately i think you know when it
comes to mass adoption people will prefer
um people will prefer convenience over everything
else right so you know how how cheap is this and
how fast is this i don't care i'm not i i do
care how decentralized it is but others may
not care how decentralized yeah but if you're
a sovereign wealth fund who needs to store
you know 20 billion dollars of bitcoin or of of
of an asset then you're gonna prefer bitcoin maybe
because of how much security you've got versus
other networks you might take eth as well because
it's pretty decentralized you know in the in the
realm of decentralization it's very decentralized
and it has a yield coming soon so you
know i can see those two assets being
on balance sheets but bitcoin is more
likely to just by the nature of what it is
yeah i want to move on actually just a little
bit to the idea of tokenization because i know
you're pretty bullish on it um they have
exploded tokens and nfts have exploded over
the last year um things seem to have calmed
down a little bit um the floor price of my
nft for example has totally just dropped i didn't
sell at the right time i'm terrible at selling
um so i'd love to get your opinion then what is
the future of nft's like what is their place in
the world um specifically though because you know
how we look at bitcoin and we go yeah that's the
sort of value ethereum yep you're the internet
specifically specifically nft is the ability
to have any contract unique contract exchangeable
storable and recordable every single contract that
is a concert ticket that is a contract for you to
turn up and the band to play that will go on nfts
it is the contract between you and an
artist i want to hold your art and i want
the rights to your art that is a contract it will
be for insurance contracts we've seen it in defy
nfts are the massive enabler to attach digital
things onto a blockchain and exchange the value
now what nfts don't do is scale because they're
unique by nature non-fungible tokens and that's
why social tokens come in because these are
the fungible elements of the same thing so
let's say you're a giant pop star you issue a
bunch of nfts they could be music rights they
could be photographs they could be concert
tickets there could be all sorts of things
but you might have a social token which
is the system of money within your network
and so that's really where
this is going and nfts have
very specific use cases and we're
just seeing the beginning of it
so annoyingly i missed the last bit of what
you just said can you just go back a little
bit i'm so sorry about the sexual token yeah
so so social tokens are the currency for these
large communities so we've seen board
yacht club is a bunch of nfts yuga labs
bunch of nfts crypto punks board 8 yacht club me
bits but they've just launched the social token
which is now allows it to scale amongst a much
larger community it becomes the operating system
of money for that community so um that is really
important that nfts themselves are the core assets
within that community and again it can be a
contract or it can be an asset itself these are
really big concepts and um you know i think people
should listen to my interview with punk 6529
that i did on real vision crypto which is
free so just get a real vision crypto.com
it's a two and a half hour interview with probably
well easily the best thinker in the entire space
and what this actually means and why it's so
important that we will not have a decentralized
web 3 future without nfts being mass adoption
same with social tokens that has to happen
what is the value though in somebody like me
for example buying a form of social token a
celebrities token what is the direct value what
do i gain from it well it depends whether the
celebrity and the community drive you value itself
so it's about the utility of that token and what
you get from it so if you get let's say it's a
big celebrity there's a big network it's vibrant
and you get first rights for concert tickets you
know things that always sell out you get first
right to merchandise you get to connect to other
fans you get rights to have meet and greets you
get the ability to be able to invest in the ip
of songs you get all these benefits from being
part of the community much like you live in the
uk that your social token is the british pound
that gives you a right to operate within the
british system you can shop within a store there
you can't shop with dollars or euros you have you
know this is what currencies do they enable the
system that you live in to operate yeah i see this
absolutely happening um it's just going to be one
of those slow growths and one thing which really
caught my eye is um you tweeted to elon musk
suggesting that twitter implement a token system a
bit like reddit so the first red flag there for me
was what about the sec isn't that going to
be security how do how would we even make
that happen from a regulatory standpoint
if you give it away it's not a security
what do you mean give it away you airdrop it
to the users okay according to use so if you
are a heavy user you get given tokens if you are
beneficial to the network you get given tokens
so then what happens is you get given
tokens exactly as the ape token did and
then it establishes a price so you have not sold
anything to anybody therefore it is not a security
and why would you and why would you not
just have what we currently have use one
of the assets that we have whether it's ethereum
whether it's doge whether it's bitcoin why would
we have to create something new because it it is
therefore specifically used for that community
and so what you're doing is you can create some
form of walled garden ways you say if you operate
within this community you earn this now if you're
in the uk and your employer says well i don't
pay you in any currency you can't pay your taxes
you can't go to the supermarket you know because
you've got yen in your bank account don't work now
can you use bitcoin for incentivisational money
of course but you get more flexibility if
you've got your own currency which is why
all governments have their own currencies as
opposed to adopting a single currency in europe
we've got a single currency but amongst a bunch
of nations and we you know we will see similar
interactions between different communities but
it means that the therefore the platform is able
to issue because if they use bitcoin who pays for
that bitcoin if i'm going to air drop it to lair
for being a great participant on twitter i now
have to go and buy bitcoin and give it to you
but if i create my own token
it doesn't cost me anything
you can accumulate tokens and we can create an
ecosystem that you can exchange these tokens
so all these people who came at me on twitter say
well you should just use the lightning network i'm
like you're missing the point it's who's going
to pay to give the 300 million twitter users
money i'm sorry it doesn't work that way what it
is is a behavioral incentive reward system that
you build value from and if you don't it shows
the network's not good and you've not created
value or utility and you should be able to earn
them by let's say you tweet a lot you get high
engagement even you don't have to be the biggest
user but your engagement's high therefore maybe
you should be given more tokens and those tokens
maybe allow you to spend it on something else
within the platform or use it for advertising
promotion of your own network or whatever it is
and so then maybe goods and services can
be transacted on twitter for those tokens
and then what will happen is the automatic market
makers will allow you to take those tokens off
and exchange them for pounds dollars bitcoin eth
whatever you want and if too much money leaves
the ecosystem it's telling you you're not adding
enough value to the ecosystem so the network's
not good it's as simple as that you sell stuff
that's not useful you keep stuff that's useful
yeah so it's all about essentially maintaining
a very healthy ecosystem i can see that because
if you don't the value goes down which is
the genius behind all of these things is
if you destroy your network by uh destroying
your community or the value of that community
your token goes down so it it incentivizes the
community to create a vibe a vibrant ecosystem
so what do you think about the
idea of a currency of the internet
having one currency that we use all over the
world and we don't have any of those annoying
cross-border payments and things like that
just one crypto why do you need to it just
sounds more convenient rather than having to
go in and out of different ways i can switch my
i can switch i can make your bitcoin payment
from my eat swap it instantaneously at zero cost
it kind of doesn't matter it's the old fiat world
where if i'm switching from cayman islands dollars
to pounds because i need to send you 50 quid
it's a nightmare takes three days costs a fortune
but this new world that's gone away now will one
currency be larger than others over time probably
which one will it be i've no idea but stable
coins have actually made the dollar very useful
because now i can send you a stable coin in
seconds yeah so you know again people are just
always looking at it through one lens without
saying what are you trying to solve we're trying
to solve instant payment system for starters well
stablecoin sold that really well now if the answer
is well i don't want fears well fine then you've
got the choice you can have you know bitcoin you
can have ethereum you can have solana whatever you
want it depends whether the other person accepts
it and if they don't then you've got an automated
market maker like uniswap he'll automatically
swap it into a different currency for you
instantaneously at almost no cost so it kind
of works pretty well i would have loved to have
seen you debate someone at the bitcoin conference
um i you know i don't
it's difficult to debate people who don't want
to who don't want to open their minds to the
fact that you can be liberal in your opinions and
you can change them over time as things change and
there's nothing wrong with thinking that bitcoin
is the only solution for you absolutely fine
why do i care and but they seem to care if anybody
else doesn't think that and that's holds true of
any maximus of anything same in religions it
doesn't make sense you know basically we all
go to a bar we socialize with each other we
shouldn't care what religion you're in what
crypto you're in but for some reason it seems to
matter so much to people um and i get it they want
to be proponents for their own network and they
want their network to survive i get that and
that is a good part of the space but it doesn't
have to be one thing fits all yeah i mean i just
think from conversations that i had the mentality
is they think everything else is dangerous and
a scam well anything else attention is essentially
um i don't know if you can hear me i think it's
frozen um giving giving it giving anything else
attention is essentially um is essentially taking
them away from the best type of money which
would allow society and humanity to flourish
that is their opinion and they're entitled
to that opinion but you can't force somebody
to have your opinion if not you're doing
what the missionaries did which was go and
go into countries and force people to take a
religion on by coercion that's not the way the
way should be by proving allowing bitcoin to
flourish and prove that it is better over time
but that is not the way it goes and this idea
that everything's a scam so one of the one of
the things that the bitcoin has held was in a bear
market bitcoin is the only one that survives and
everything else goes to zero since the bear market
ethan's outperformed and i'm not saying that as an
ethmax i'm not i don't give a [ __ ] what currency
what works over time i literally don't care um
i would care for the whole space that's what i
care about i really care about this whole space
um but the point is ethel performed so it's like
huh that's not the narrative the narrative is
they all get exposed in a bear market
it's all narrative and it's not true
it's just simply not true is bitcoin what is
true is bitcoin the most decentralized strongest
most robust network yes true is it the only
answer to everything absolutely categorically no
which leads me on my next topic actually um i want
to get into web 3 because you've probably said
that um web 3 bitcoin and ethel will change every
business model i really want to understand how
and what that means for content creators like me
because i you know i'm putting the interview out
on and put interview out on youtube so will i have
to migrate to a different platform will there be
just one platform what does it mean i think that
all platforms will adopt it and i've spoken to a
lot of people at youtube and i've spoken to a
lot of people at meta and all of this i think
they understand where this is going and i think
that they understand that leia needs to be in
charge of our own audience and therefore doesn't
need a third party advertiser you may choose to
but you also don't want your eyeballs necessarily
monetized without sharing some of the economics
of that which you do somewhat but not a lot of
and the ability for you to be rewarding fans
with tokens and digital assets for your super fans
and be able to engage with them on these platforms
is going to drive the land network bigger and more
vibrant so now you're working directly for your
fans right now all you get is engagement so you
look at your twitter numbers you look at youtube
numbers that's all you're getting and in exchange
you're getting a share of the ad revenue from
google nothing from twitter and you're getting
um sponsorship revenue because you've got reach
but if you're in charge of your own sovereign
state of liar and you you do it that way where
you've got your own system of tokens nfts you give
people access to you so you can have you know 100
people on a zoom call together and they get to
talk to you once every month and given different
layers of access that becomes web 3 where the
community owns a share of their community so
they're working with the influencer right now
i watch you on youtube i'm being served ads for
the privilege of watching it why should that
be now again ads aren't inherently evil what's
evil is the fact that we're all getting
monetized and nobody's getting a share of it or
a significant share in it and we can change that
via web three where where communities participate
in the networks much like in bitcoin you hold a
bitcoin and you're now a network participant and
you're incentivized to grow the network which
is why people get very passionate about it
well if your fans were interested in growing your
network and they wanted and they were going to get
financial benefit from doing so well that digital
marketing explodes it changes everything so
this is why it's going to change every business
model because if you think about a fashion brand
nike or adidas or anybody they pay so much
in marketing costs they're paying to google
they're paying to facebook they're paying in
newspapers they're paying to billboards they're
paying to conferences they're paying paying
paying now if you tokenize that community
you can get rid of all of that layer of costs
and get your audience or your community members
to promote your products for you because they're
going to be incentivizing on tick tock and make
videos about them or make youtube content or
tweets about it because the more people who
buy the product and come into the network the
more valuable the network becomes because the
network gets a share of it so let's say you're
a music fan and you buy a token in rihanna's new
album and you buy the fractionalized part of
one song the ip for the first three months
so you're now going to go on tick tock all day
and try and promote that one song if that song
becomes a hit you'll make a money from it so that
sports that the pop star now does not have to pay
for marketing she's not paying google and facebook
they're not doing anything the the members are
doing it because they're incentivized to do
it much like everybody in the bitcoin network
is incentivized to get people on board into
bitcoin because the value of bitcoin goes up
fast donating um i understand again it's about
creating that economy and that i'm saying i
understand it's really interesting it's about
creating that economy and that ecosystem um
that's going to take some time to get to i think
um but what i don't understand is like how it
looks practically because i keep you know i think
it'll take some time to get to i don't think so
all of this space is moving much faster than
you can ever possibly imagine so i'm working
on this space a lot of people are this is
what nfts are nfc is exploded onto the screen
you know onto the scene right they're coming
so fast this space is growing the crypto space
overall is growing at 137 a year and the internet
back at roughly the same stage was growing at 65
a year it is twice the speed i see this many times
people that understand what i'm talking about
twice the speed of the internet in terms of
adoption so if it's growing 137 a year now
we're at 300 million users we're at six or seven
hundred million users this time next year we're
at one and a half billion users the year after
now that will happen at scale because of what
these giant communities are going to do the giant
communities being fashion brands music sports um
film franchises tv all of this they're
all coming into these new business models
so on a practical standpoint though how's it
going to look because i keep hearing people say
um you know you it's really you own your
it's really simple on here you will get paid
into your wallet for participating
in the communities that you belong to
so maybe there's a beauty brand you're involved in
that you really like that you think is really cool
and maybe there's a a bunch of influencers you're
involved in some music and bitcoin right so maybe
those are your cultural things and maybe a fashion
brand that you love as well right and you're part
of the community you're helping promote it you're
doing stuff you want to be involved you have the
tokens on your phone and these are like universal
basic equity because you're earning them by being
a a person in the network who's doing good for
the community and so you've got a bunch of these
things that are valuable that you've not had to
pay for in many circumstances you may want to
buy more because you really believe in it but you
may get awarded them so you're getting free money
for being a good community member and helping
drive those networks and they'll all be on your
mobile phone and then you will be able to spend
them either within that network or exchange them
outside of that network for other things so
it's a world of having multiple currencies
for multiple things like when you go on holiday
to spain you have to use euros and if you go on
holiday to australia you need aussie dollars so
you are leaving one community going to another
and you use their currency it's the same
but we're going down to smaller currencies
but in terms of platforms are we saying like
twitter's still going to exist will youtube
exist or will there just be one platform no
it'll be across everywhere now does it mean that
meta screw it up and get it wrong and people
leave possibly do twitter adopt this fast enough
who knows it's bloody hard to build a new twitter
because there's 300 million people using all day
so the most likely outcome is twitter say we're
going to integrate this world which is why i
tweeted elon musk because this is where they're
going to have to go if they want hyper engagement
if they don't want to sell ads and
they want to create a reward system
that makes twitter a better place
because therefore if you're a bad network
participant then the value of the network goes
down so it stops people destroying networks so
it's going to be across all platforms you won't
even notice it it'll just be part of what you do
much like you go into this financial world and
suddenly you own shares and all of these things
now they're on different stock exchanges
you can use different brokerages
they already care you've got to share
an apple you've got sharing you know
facebook whatever it is so it's it's that
world it's a multi-asset world that operates
across different chains that are and we can
transfer the assets from one to the other
back it cut out a little bit but i i got what
you said um this internet is not good i need to
get this sorted um yeah no i think i think it's
been really fascinating um i want to just move
on a little bit um and talk about um more to do
with regulation um we're sort of not really sure
what's going on right now i know that you're a
big advocate for mass adoption only being able
to happen with regulation um sort of a regulation
being inevitable um so how is this all going to
move forward with um regulation and you know
sec we sort of touched on that they've made
it really clear and i said this ages ago gary
genzer came out all guns blazing and said we
want to ban everything everything's terrible that
is classic negotiation tactics you start with the
hardest line first and you try and negotiate
to the center and you try and keep it a bit on
your side so he tried to go in hard he hasn't
even got the mandate the cftc haven't got the
mandate nobody's got the mandate yet so they're
trying to do this um this cross-governmental um
um policy committee to do this but what they've
said is yeah we get it it's real it's happening
and we have to work with it so it's exactly
playing out as i said it would is they will reach
a decent compromise they will have to rewrite some
laws like the securities laws and the howie test
over time because they'll realize it's not going
to work and if the u.s wants to be a world leader
they have to change that europe doesn't have
a howie test europe has other issues however
you know and so people are going to figure this
out over time and the uk made a great statement
of what they're trying to do they've said yep we
get it web 3 is coming stable coins are part of
the economy we think they're good uh we understand
that that the world is changing and we're going to
allow this to happen and we'll have a like light
touch regulation best we can and we're going to
be adaptive so we know the space is moving
so there's no point trying to regulate it
with an iron fist now let's see how
it goes everyone's going to do that
it's too big you can't have it you know as i said
by next year there's 700 million people using this
what are you going to do just suddenly
say no it's just not going to happen
so all it is is them being comfortable
that they get their share of taxes
yes and the shenanigans aren't going on that's all
it is and we make it you know everyone's you know
shaking their fists screaming at each other but
that's all they really care about is please don't
destroy our own system of money uh try not to
hide money from bad things and that's basically it
and then we continue as normal i totally agree
yeah and this space just keeps growing super
fast because because they accept it you
mentioned stable coins um and i actually
want to ask you about that where do you see
stable coins playing out um in in the global
there we go we're back sorry what can i do
right my question was cbdc's versus stable coins
the uk has made it clear and i think the fed
has made it pretty clear they're both going to
probably coincide and operate with each other what
i think seems to be moving towards is the central
banks will have their own version so let's say
they want to have hand out stimulus you can give
it directly to people's wallets maybe and maybe
the government has a wallet of which you pay your
taxes from or whatever but you'll have private
wallets private cbd private stable coins i think
they're accepting that technology moves too fast
to not use existing rails that the private sector
has built i think they're all going to come to
that solution singapore got to that solution too
i think india's coming to that solution that
they're gonna have to use all sorts of different
uh existing blockchain rails now what blockchains
they're built on who knows nobody cares
um you know they will just be built on different
things and you know people hate it but a bunch
of stuff will get built on you know xrp a bunch
of stuff will get built on on some layer of eats
some will get built on you know cosmos nobody
cares as long as i can send you the dollar
well i'm going to leave it there because
the wi-fi is too tough um but i want to
thank you so much it's been such
a pleasure um it's always really
fascinating to talk about um web3 in the
metaverse because that's something that i
i know is inevitable but i struggle to
fully um you know understand um so i really
appreciate you taking the time and also just
dealing with the wi-fi it's been a bit hectic
not at all not at all i hope i didn't rile too
many people up by being wildly liberal um in uh
in the space but you know just it's an exciting
place and we just let it develop as it develops
yeah absolutely hopefully i'll catch up with you
again um when the wi-fi is a little bit better
because i still have a few more questions but
i'll leave with that for now i want to thank you
so much for coming on and thank you everyone for
joining we'll see you next time take care thanks